in five four three two one no
introduction needed you sexy sons of
[ __ ] welcome back to another episode
of the genius brain podcast I have a
very very special guest and I always say
special but this one's really special oh
because next to him if you're watching
this on video
I look like a goblin and you and you
address it you were dressed in a leather
jacket while I look like a like a
healthy vagina today is there pink in a
vagina yes there is I'm sorry yellow
pink of course yes you should know
you're married in fact I have you right
you look like a pink lemonade today we
have Yoshi Sood are so now you may
remember him from a video where I groped
him and I slapped his fresh little tushy
mmm yes and I did that as a heterosexual
male and I am completely okay with that
you should be you should be okay to sub
yoshi what's up boo boo so we've been
trading together yeah
yes kicking my ass is full does not know
how strong he is you know I'm still sore
from from a blast how we were all about
Friday oh I'm still sore I don't because
when we roll I don't do that often
but yeah you know because I'm so new to
it really oh yeah I'm so tense oh my
triceps or my bicep buy back and my
groin was sore just because I'm not used
to you know when we win it when you have
psyche control you have to kind of like
spread your legs on them put your weight
on somebody got sore from that that's
the flexibility you don't want a
freaking stretch with me that's what is
me I feel like I'm in prison we should
actually show Home Videos so bad so good
afterwards you like ah so great it's so
much [ __ ] about it the whole way
through that's good I'm not a stuntman
dude I don't do that I like to complain
my way through things dude yeah no no we
complain all the time well you're
getting good no no I don't like sparring
that much oh my god just because like
it's painful yes exactly yeah
I prefer I prefer I could partner drills
yeah yeah partner drills are fun and
that way you get like used to the
movements like I feel like when I'm
sparring I'm just
close my eyes when you it's cuz when we
start doing partner drills more often
I'm gonna start to click for you yeah so
we do partner you have partner to a
partner drill that eventually starts to
go into your sparring and then after a
while it just happens so like I don't
have much set combos but because I'm
more used to kicking well you know I
like to set up my kicks a lot so a lot
of the times when your [ __ ] kicks he
blasted me three in a row and each time
he did he kind of looked at me was like
hey you gotta block that I'm like I'm
trying each one yeah like I uh it's
interesting because like Bart might when
I sparred about Bart has like
cinderblock hands so he had my full
whole face hurts but you know he's going
sausages he has heavy [ __ ] hands he's
just a solid dude yeah so I'm glad he
uses 16-ounce gloves if he doesn't I'd
be a porter now but you have a you have
a movie coming out
oh so check this out dude I don't do do
you remember the first time I met you I
can't I can't I can't remember the exact
not exact yeah yeah but you were doing
stunts so he was doing stunts at
Universal Studios right oh yeah okay
this fool lost his [ __ ] front teeth I
how the [ __ ] did that happen
alright so okay Universal Studios that I
don't know how many people have actually
seen the show but there's an character
who gets lit on fire and he falls 45
feet to his death or into the water
right yeah and so I I do that part and
that's just one of the things that we do
on the show and when we were learning it
the first couple weeks of rehearsal you
know I'd never done anything like that
they hired me because I could jump from
that high and it was fine they're like
well you have to fall a specific way and
the reason why you have to fall a
specific ways because there's fire on
you and you want to keep the fire behind
you so you want to run and fall forward
and as you're falling forward you want
to keep that fire behind you and as you
fall forward your head dips sort of
closer to the water and at that point
the fire will envelop you so you have to
turn when that point happens so that the
fire is now still behind you so
basically like if you're here your head
is facing the water you're going down
the fires behind you as you're falling
like this the fire is gonna do this so
you have to turn so you fall this way
it's so confusing
what if actually pretty simple no one's
mad once you get it you see it basically
you just want to keep the fire behind
you at all times
and if you don't twist the fire will
involve you basically because if you
keep falling like this and all the way
it'll just cover you so basically you
just want to keep the fire behind you
and so the move is you it's called a
step off Brandi oh shut up Cirie its
podcast world doesn't matter they can be
distractions anyway so that's the idea
you step off Brandi you miss one leg and
you fall and spin and follow it back
onto your feet I've never known that
they were like I'll do it it's just like
a cartwheel it's fine I do it just like
a cartwheel basically they're like it's
a cartwheel you know you just and then
as you're falling you miss your leg and
you keep twisting I was like ooh so yeah
I'll try it right I cartwheel to my left
and I twist to my left which is a
problem they do opposite day cartwheels
to that right and they twist to their
left so when I did it I take off my leg
left leg out and I try to spin it
actually like barreled me double times
and it spun me out of control I fell
flat on my face and the speed and the
high hitting the water felt like
concrete oh and I basically hit the
water like this on my chin and it is
what I clap I didn't have my teeth
closed so I collect
luckily my tongue wasn't out or I'll
blast my tongue but I clapped my teeth
together and it just cracked the top six
and when I got out I was like you know
that hurt like a mother but there are
you okay like yeah just my tongue feels
weird what and I spat all my teeth out I
was like oh that's not good
but it was like a whole year process and
they not getting screamed I would have
screamed it was pretty bad when you when
you how was your bottom teeth the bottom
teeth are fine cuz it's the bottom I had
a pretty bad buck tooth mmm so the
bottom teeth kind of hit it at an angle
where it was like half you know what I'm
saying like it wasn't like this it hit
like that because so I hit the Hat the
the back half of my tooth so it cracked
the half to the bottom so I had like
shark teeth for a while and I went so it
was on a Friday it happened on Friday so
I went to the doctor's that day and
dentist they checked x-ray make sure my
nothing was broken my ribs weren't
broken I was bruised my chest was
bruised and you know my chin was bruised
but nothing was broken aside for my
teeth so it's at a dentist they gave me
these fake caps for the weekend yeah and
they were like we're gonna get you
veneers all that stuff it's gonna be
great I was like cool what is the
process for veneers so it's different
for everyone it depends on what it is so
three of my teeth were cracked all the
way to the roots so they have to do root
canal and put like yeah I guess a beam
or whatever in those three teeth the
other ones were just cracked to half of
it so they could just put a cap over it
they like smooth it out put a cap over
it and it's done but the others that I
have to do root canal so I had to wait
for all the root canals and he can only
do one at a time or someone of that and
also they were like hey it looks like
your teeth kind of got pushed forward
when you did it so we kind of have to
we're gonna have to like pull it back
otherwise you'll have you know buck
teeth and I was like a bit heavy but
they didn't need to know that yeah so
basically they fixed my teeth they you
know kind of put retainers to pull my
teeth back I had braces all throughout
high school like headgear and everything
so it did it was already like I had bad
buck tooth like out to here I couldn't
close my mouth and then they have to
pull it back in for high school and then
it kind of went back because of not
wearing retainers and then when I hit my
teeth it went out even further so they
kind of pulled it back to I guess an
aesthetic position
and [ __ ] so they did that all for free
because it was owner insurance
technically because it happened on the
job
yeah and so it was all about a year long
process mostly because they had to pull
the teeth back yeah and then so I had
like temporary veneers for about a year
and that [ __ ] kept popping off like I
would lose it I would like I wake up and
there wasn't you know I'd lose a tooth I
was like where'd it go so I'd have to go
to the dentist and they'd have to put it
back in whatever it be loose oh man it
was a pain in the butt I couldn't close
my mouth until after that happened like
when any like photos that I have I was
like I had a bit of a gap because my
mouth couldn't close holy [ __ ] how much
do you know how much that would have
caught it was about like above above 10
grand yeah so it was good it was a
blessing in disguise
well how did you lose your teeth in they
ask your kid you're like I'm fine I was
like it didn't hurt but I was like I'm
good I'm not like I don't feel anything
horrible except my tongue feels weird
have a good threshold for pain
well that was a thing as soon as I spat
my teeth I was like ah and I did that
and all the wind went up my nerves aw
dude I fell to my knees because it was
so change I did not realize I was like
as soon as I did that all the wind just
hit all my nerves - nerves I didn't go
to a dentist for like years right cuz I
was like haha my teeth are [ __ ] fine
I've never had I never had a cavity so I
don't know what that [ __ ] was like I
[ __ ] hate the dentist so I haven't
gone in years and then Merida was my
girlfriend she was just you know you
should probably go to the dentist right
cuz I started having tooth aches of [ __ ]
and I was like I think that I never had
a [ __ ] cavity before now mind you the
biggest reasons why I've never had a
cavity because I you know I was brush my
teeth I do all the other [ __ ] but I
never drink soda I don't religion candy
and nothing nothing that really corrodes
my teeth not until like six years ago I
started drinking a lot of soda so terms
of like Diet Coke
like I love Diet Coke for some reason I
don't know why my diet coke that's not
even say this is good I don't know why
but so here's the thing like I I didn't
used to like that [ __ ] and then [ __ ]
two people in my life my friend Dan
Fisher and then Bart got me in the soda
these stupid sons of [ __ ] because he
would talk about sort of like his
delicious like bar talks about zone
like a crack it talks about [ __ ] the
crack rocks like that's exactly how he
talks about it he's like dude when you
fill it up with this tall glass and you
put like 75% ice and you pour that coke
can in there I'm like you know I I
didn't really like soda like I like soda
here and there but it would be only with
like pizza or a burger or something
right yeah but you know he got me to the
point where I just like to drink soda in
general and then next thing you know I'm
sorry again toothaches is [ __ ] and lo
and behold I had three cavities and then
I talked to my dentist and they're like
oh how many calories have you had before
I was like I've never had cavities
before I'm like oh that's pretty good
for somebody your age like nobody for
not having cavities so and I haven't had
a deep cleaning or anything or
recovering in a while okay and so
they're like oh you need a deep cleaning
now and the first of all I've never had
a deep cleaning before I didn't know
what that [ __ ] feels like right and so
though so I'm talking to the lady and
she goes I was like well for the deep
clean does it really hurt she goes
doesn't hurt how's like it'll be fine
and I was like well well she goes but
you know some people do find it painful
so we could give you a couple of shots
numbing shots and then you'll be okay
like all I'm sayin you said some people
I'm not some people just numb it out
I'll be fine I just numb it out what the
[ __ ] don't put me in the category of
these some people ain't no [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] them
just put the gel on she does talk I'm
talking about the first five seconds as
it but I'm so [ __ ] stubborn I just
took the pain for the the first session
for the first half of my face and they
only do half your face because it swells
up so much and it hurts so after we were
done she goes so it wasn't that bad
right I looked at this [ __ ] right in
her face I said you [ __ ] lied to me
the worst pains of my life how dare you
she goes oh you didn't say anything else
because I didn't want to be a [ __ ] I
was like how many people just get the
numbing thing she goes almost nobody
doesn't then you [ __ ] liar I wasn't
so much pain it hurts so bad they
literally just take this rotating drill
and he grind your teeth down like I had
no idea
nobody told me nobody [ __ ] told me
that's what it like and you just get
this steel hook and they just drag it
across your teeth
it feels like they're ripping chunks of
my gum out that's what it felt like and
nobody told me that [ __ ] dude I [ __ ]
hate the dentist bro I've lived with the
dentist like forever since I was no
little kid I was like seventh grade all
the way to junior year in high school I
had my teeth were so bad
braces for four plus years yeah and do
you know what a headgear is uh yeah I
might remember seeing four like so yeah
it's basically they get this metal piece
and in your braces itself has a metal
piece that has a hole in it and you
click it onto it and then it wraps
around your head and you tighten that
[ __ ]
so basically pulls everything back
because my buck tooth were so bad that
they needed more than just the braces to
pull it I didn't have a good childhood
high school time dude what how did you
get bullied in high school like your big
was like no that was this height but a
hundred twenty-five pounds 125 pounds
and [ __ ] up teeth hey everybody said I
had green aids for breakfast
it's a messed up teeth and Peter has
never had braces he's got perfect teeth
Oh what the [ __ ] he has never had to get
braces his teeth are perfect it looks
like it's veneers yeah but I have
perfect eyesight and he's got horrible
eyesight okay
so we're like I could wear glasses and I
got a freakin headgear on my head
surely you weren't born here right no no
we were both born in Indonesia when did
you guys come here nine years old well I
was dying it was like 1998 oh you that's
that's fairly late yeah yeah oh [ __ ] so
when you you couldn't speak any English
no none well I mean we knew a little bit
like yo I remember this one phrase that
my teacher in Indonesia the English
teacher taught us
may I please want to go bathroom swear
you that is exactly what I learned on
how to use to how to ask to use read
that stupid [ __ ] I was like that what
the [ __ ] English you trying to get me
messed up out here yeah
yeah it was like bad grammar bad you
know you don't say bathroom you say
restroom bathroom is like for your house
like ah of them in school asking for the
bathroom they're like the restroom is
over here oh my god that must have been
rough though not knowing how to speak
English yeah but we got we were lucky in
the sense of we we were able to Peter
and I we were like I know more
internation we can't speak to each other
in it and we weren't that tight anyways
with each other at that age so we didn't
have any friends who spoke in an Asian
so we were like forced to go full mode
like just learn the English or you're
[ __ ]
yeah but because of that our accent is
pretty pretty much diminished Peter has
like no accent I've got a little bit but
compared to him yeah you have I I
wouldn't have noticed it unless you
mentioned a while ago yeah I wouldn't
have noticed but like for yeah Peter you
would never know yeah and that's why his
Indonesian is also worse than mine
oh is it yeah I I well I can speak it
better I mean it granted I've been
working there now lately and and that
helps for me to get it back but even
before that my Indonesian accent was
already better bully because of that
[ __ ] because I know like it's it's kind
of hard especially like at that age like
I think kids don't understand that
people are different and they just even
adults do that [ __ ] but it's worse when
you're kids
yeah well the stupid thing is like I
went to a predominantly Asian school so
I wasn't bullied for being Asian because
everybody else was [ __ ] Asian yeah
but it was like I was a weird type of
Asian like they're like what kind of
food is this you know they were used to
it was mostly Korean and Filipino and I
was like Filipinos food is similar like
woody but they were I had certain foods
that that just was weird and and I what
they were like Indonesia where is
Indonesia yeah it was just I don't know
it was a weird thing that I was like
thinking back I'm like we were all
Asians dude like you know like
Indonesian food when I first had it I
couldn't like put my finger on it like I
when I ate it I thought oh this is some
different [ __ ] it's different and it
likes sweet they like spicy it's just
all over the place like I don't know I
don't know how to put my finger on it
right so if somebody told me like oh
what is
Indonesian food like as I [ __ ] I don't
know man it's like a mix between like
Thai food Indian food and Filipino food
like that's actually the perfect way to
that's what I would have said yeah yeah
but it looks it tastes more mild than it
looks
so like Thai foods in tensest [ __ ]
everything is so intense right and it's
it's delicious in its own right but
Indonesian food looks like that
but then it's it's toned down and you
can't describe Indonesian food as
Singaporean food like in because then
what the [ __ ] is that everything like
Malaysian food like what's Malaysian
food you know it's just like a mix
between all that time it nummies it's
just all that punched in the one and it
was so just because I you know I took
you guys to the Borneo yeah that place
is so damn good man and that's the first
time I had cuz I used to always eat the
the Indo me the the V Garre the little
package ad said pack the 40 cent pack
[ __ ] [ __ ] I've never had the real
[ __ ] before this is what its gonna taste
like but it doesn't yeah and that the
handmade noodles are so [ __ ] good man
bro we got I gotta take you because
there's like in Indonesia they have this
thicker noodle that's like if I mean I
like I love thick noodles better than
thin noodles so like me going and all
those stuff they're thinner noodles but
there's a bunch of places in Indonesia
that where they make their noodles and
it's hand-pulled noodles and it's we
call it meekly thing and then or mikata
and it's like thicker basically correct
means rubber but is like it's thick and
it's oh dude so juicy the Indonesian
language sounds like it literally sounds
like a Filipino person with dementia
it's so [ __ ] wild because I was
watching um the rain one of my favorite
like indie action films ever dude it is
so [ __ ] intense yeah and so was
watching the raid it the translations
crack me up it would be like this a
whole bunch of Indonesian words and then
the translation just says where are you
[ __ ] did all these syllables and sounds
come from dude the language isn't in
tents nothing sounds like it yeah
nothing's not like Indonesian the
closest would be Tagalog yeah
we actually have similar words actual
the same words but we're I think we're
quicker yeah we're like yeah yeah we're
fast and it's it's hard because
sometimes I'm like because I think of
how it's actually not that fast but when
you are hearing it it sounds fast and
then so when I speak it I try to talk a
little faster and they're like you slow
down yeah okay I'm just going too fast
it's like Hindi and Filipino like the
Filipino like the Gauley put together or
something yes it's so [ __ ] wild
well you were but you weren't Indonesia
to do a film I was yeah I did that so a
year and a half ago I agent just calls
me out of nowhere I was like yo we got a
film for you they want you to play this
character I didn't know what it was I I
was like okay is it a small carrot I
don't remember auditioning for this like
no it's from Indonesia I was like whoa
home country that's kind of cool yeah
yeah I'll take a look at it and read
that the script was all full in English
and and I you know you do like that
that's search for the character name and
it was like oh my name comes up a lot
mmm like them yeah I'm either a pretty
main character or I get talked about a
lot yeah like they just decided it's you
Dollywood talking to you they're like
it's gonna be him
well exactly that's why I was like
there's no way it's a main character
yeah I finished reading it I was like yo
he's I think he's the lead yeah they're
like yeah I think so too uh you know and
you're like I don't know what's going on
okay let's let's have a chat with this
director and I chatted with the director
like three days after the script and he
was like yeah so how's your endo um I
was like it's not that great he's like
it's okay mine's not like good either
but the script is gonna be it's gonna be
like half endo half English you cook
cool that I was like sure it should be
okay you know cuz it's a script I can
memorize it and then he was like cool I
want you here next week holy [ __ ] yeah I
was like I mean talk to my agents make
sure everything's cool and whatever he's
like yep within a week I was in
Indonesia prepping for the film Oh what
the [ __ ] oh the reason why it was so
quick cuz like I had a month of prep and
and we shot for two months and the
reason why I was so quick was because
basically they had been trying to do
this movie for about two years
oh sure it is a passion project of the
director
it's a Western ray and and that's not
been done in Indonesia before and to the
scale that it was so basically they've
been pushing for this for two years and
they'd already cast everybody my
character was cast well wha come to the
time where it was gonna shoot because
they kept pushing him back pushing him
back the guy who had already booked
another film in Korea playing like the
lead villain so he was like I don't I
can't leave I'm gonna he's stuck on this
so they had to recast they looked for
castings in Indonesia and there just
wasn't somebody who had the English and
had the Indo I think and it was just
like I think he wanted also a fresh face
I don't know what it was that made it
but God put it all together and he was
like here you go take your coz I was
like yo how did you find me he's like I
honestly don't remember
and then you just kept popping up out of
nowhere so I decided to reach out to
your agents you know I was like so you
don't really remember how you found me I
have no idea it's probably like looking
up Google or whatever you know I was
like that's crazy yeah it was really
crazy and I'd never you know like a
direct book that's that's out of my
world like I was never you know somebody
who would get direct book for anything
so it was really cool to to do this and
in the fact that it was a character the
character itself was born in Indonesia
moved to America learned the many ways
yeah and they came back it was like wait
what No yeah so basically when I went
back I was like I don't know what I'm
doing and it's paralleled so well
because in the movie that happens a lot
I do stupid things and they're like you
know it's not how you do things here
whereas for me I grew up in Indonesia
and I spoke the language but only as a 9
year old right that was the MA way I
spoke was a bit childish and in
Indonesia
you don't usually sometimes you don't
say I blow a lot it's you say your name
so like a third person like yo she would
like some water whatever right something
like that and that's what how I spoke to
my parents I did still and that was
normal and when I went to Indonesia I
kind of hung out more with the two girl
co-stars because my the guy co-star he
was on another film for a while so he
wasn't prepping with us so the two girls
were hanging out with me mostly in they
were helping me with the Indonesian and
all that stuff we were working on
script and every time they were asked
like oh maybe thought you want something
she'll be like yep Evita wants me going
for lunch whatever right so I got used
to this I would do the same thing and I
would I was trying to speak my endo like
use it more practice it now to do that
and then you know people would hear that
and then after a month of this and we
started going to shooting the Geico star
we've gotten closer but he's heard me
say it all that stuff and he kind of
looks at me like during a break
because I said it like I was like oh she
wants whatever right so he was like he
looks at me he's like man I really like
you and I think there's gonna be great
like you're a cool dude he was from New
Zealand yeah he was like the same thing
nine years old moves to New Zealand grew
up there but when he was 18 he moved to
Indonesia to pursue acting oh she's in
there for about 10 years yeah path over
me you know and he was like so hidden
knows great now but he also had that
same thing and he was like like I love
you man but why do you keep talking
about yourself in the third person like
you mean yeah everybody everyone's doing
like he's like who I've always done it
you know growing up and Pepita and Mika
does it you know yeah two girls
he was like yeah if you're a girl are
you trying to be cute okay oh my god are
you kidding me he's like yeah you're
basically walking around saying the
girls didn't think anything of it cuz
they're like ah how cute that's so
[ __ ] funny dude and then all the
people who were like getting me the food
it said oh they were like afraid to say
anything like okay we're like the lead
right they didn't want to make me feel
bad or whatever but he was like dude
it's kind of it's annoying you need to
stop I was like thank you I had no idea
you should have said something you
[ __ ] dumbass [ __ ] can I can I please
have some water mortifying dude yeah I
was like and I'm over here trying to be
the tough guy I'll play the character
who's like oh yeah oh my god I was like
that's crazy but when you went back to
it when you were there for a while dude
so I was out there for three
initially for that first yeah it was a
long time dude
and then I I left I came back here and
then the movie came out within six
months so they were like come on back
we're gonna premiere the movie we need
you here for a month of like interviews
this and that and that so I stayed for a
month and when the movie premiered a
director saw the movie and it was like
he's the guy I've been looking for for
my next movie so he was like hey my
movie starts in like less than a month
you mind sticking around prepping for
this movie and then we'll shoot the
movie and you can go home so I stayed
for another basically three months to do
this next film but this next film was
harder because it was that my last
character like he was born in Indonesia
yeah yeah so there was a reason why his
Indonesian wasn't good this character I
was like oh so you gotta practice and it
was slaying like the first one at least
it was like formal you know so no matter
what's gonna sound a little awkward and
it's okay because it's a period piece
that's fine yeah whereas this one was
slaying and I was like it's it's like
somebody who's completely an immigrant
me like yo what's up dog that kind of
thing is just not right like hitting it
right and I was like I don't want to not
hit it right and they're like we'll work
with you and it that one was harder way
way way harder but they were like it's
fine because you sound like the in
donations who've lived there all their
lives
but they went to an international school
okay and then the character is a rich
kid yeah so it's okay for that I was
like okay okay I'll take that that's
crazy
yeah what what age do you normally play
when you do these films cuz you yeah so
here I look hella young I can play maybe
25 at the oldest right yeah unless I
grow beard whatever so in Indo I played
the first one was a 28 year old but I
had a full beard and then the second one
I played a 30 year old but I did not
have a beard yeah but it's okay because
everybody else looks yeah that's why
everyone else looks younger you look
young but over there you're just normal
I just I'm like a normal person cuz
everyone else was that your actual
facial hair yeah I shaved two days ago
[ __ ] as far as this comes out that's
hilarious I have not been able to grow
facial hair well like anywhere
I only started going Lake here when I
was like 20 no way yeah so I'm like here
yeah like Lake here when I was 20 and
then I started growing this facial I
like this here and here like this other
stuff here probably like two years ago
Wow
yeah so like I didn't know that I was
walking around like with like these
little strands of hair and I just didn't
have them and then my mom looked at me
she goes why do you look so [ __ ]
dirty I was like what do you mean she
goes shave your the under part of your
[ __ ] neck you do when I looked at you
she sees long like strands here and I
never noticed it out of nowhere it just
started growing
I was like yeah what the [ __ ] yo I still
have the the shaving cream back at home
I don't know where it is now maybe my
mom throw it away now but when I went
back like a year or two ago the same can
of shaving cream my mom got me in
college for as a going-away things
everything use I've never had to use it
it was it's like this white and navy
blue Nevaeh [ __ ] men's shaving cream
and I have the same way I just did it's
there and just it's like [ __ ] like
ten years old like I've never needed to
use it but I mean like so you use you
would use a razor if you shaved rather
than like there's like a couple of
strands but it was I didn't need shaving
cream for seven hairs you know it would
just swipe swipe swipe and I was done
the only time I'll you shaving [ __ ]
shave my pubes that's about it that's
not good I need this one now but other
than that like I just never had facial
hair like even like my arms are relative
yeah cuz I have I have facial I have
hair yes I gonna veins yeah you buff
[ __ ] you have any idea if I look
like you I would use it for evil I
didn't use oh my god I would use it for
evil I have to giggle my way into the
[ __ ] dude this just sucks
and you've been in love with your girls
this you were like three years old you
[ __ ] loser who does that nine bro
nine that's right my bad nine so this is
the this is the dumbest thing I've ever
heard of my life but it's very dumb
because it's cute he has been in love
with the same girl since he moved to
America and then married this girl till
this day they're still together it's the
craziest [ __ ] thing I've ever heard
in my life
you guys have been they get this is she
were nine or ten no no we've been
together since we were I was 21 21
like she loved her since I was nine I
I saw her I met her and I was like mom
that's the girl I want to marry and it
took me 12 years to get her to like me
but she also the thing is she was like
so good she didn't date anyone in high
school oh really I'm her first boyfriend
oh [ __ ] yeah what the [ __ ] that's wild
she listened to her parents when her
parents are like no dating until after
high school and after high school she
was like okay I mean when it happens it
happens and yeah I just happened to be
the one that was there holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude well what do you remember as a nine
year old when you saw heard that made
you said imma get that ass you were said
I mean I totally remember it I mean I
set it in Indo obviously cuz I didn't
speak a language and I remember Peter
going like oh I'm gonna help this fool
out but like when we were like a year
older we had sort of English repertoire
you know Peter told her friends yeah so
like yo can you come up kind of thing
but that wasn't what happened her
friends like yeah she likes it I hated
it Peter for it I like you son of a
[ __ ] what do that little ATD
[ __ ] I know why wouldn't you do
that you so sure it was a good liar yeah
but you know that I had ended up being
it's so funny he's like you know what my
brother needs some help I might help him
get this [ __ ] [ __ ] this American
[ __ ] you stupid son of a [ __ ] oh this
[ __ ] and mean the thing is like Sarah
was like the princess of our church
right so we had all the guys that we
were all friends with were all liked her
so we were like yo it was like 13 years
old we all made a pact no one's gonna
ask her out no one's gonna date her yeah
do that cuz it's gonna just break up our
friendship okay yeah so when I finally
got with her right I was like stupid ass
21 year old being like man I feel bad I
made a pact with my boys you know saying
you are so stupid dude that [ __ ] was
when you were nine years old you shut
the [ __ ] up right now as a holder that
[ __ ] matter
I hate told her about it and she was
like they've both asked me out I was
like when one of them asked her out when
he was 15 in high school and I was like
that was like a couple years after the
pact and the other one asked her out
after high school
and I was like these treacherous
bastards she or she was I see you know
what oh dude that stuff that's so
[ __ ] funny dude that's son of a [ __ ]
you should've talked to me you
[ __ ] looks like what happened
or pact one of them is I I don't
remember a pact of lies like I didn't
even speak English back then and I
remembered it that's whoa dude so wait
well I mean what made her to say yes to
you compared to the other two guys then
dude come on you [ __ ] dragons [ __ ]
[ __ ] up buck teeth with a headgear
[ __ ] I don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about
yo when she got with me I still had
hella acne and my my teeth were still
[ __ ] though
oh really yeah yeah you had bad acne
sick I was like 15 16 like right around
the time like my braces disappeared acne
came I was like are you kidding me
what the [ __ ] and it was bad it was like
all down here and then up here and this
is it was always here for me the tea oh
dude it's so bad I know I tried so many
things you know the what is it the thing
that was always on TV elective yes
Proactiv yeah I tried it so many
different times never worked it just
made my dress like skin so dry yeah it
was horrible I tried avvocato on my face
oh my god I try the best one that
actually worked
cinnamon and cinnamon and honey really
you put cinnamon like in a little bowl
and you put honey on it and you mix it
and it looks like [ __ ] and you put it on
your face and it looks like somebody
took a dump on you like a wet dump but
it works it alleviates it it's it's not
as redness yeah it's not as hot and you
know you want to scratch it yeah that
goes away and it I mean I don't have
scarring yeah so well how'd you find out
about the cinnamon honey [ __ ] dude my
mom I'll really I would hate that [ __ ]
that's my fat ass my my mom gave me so
many different remedies and she Asian as
hell and I was like it's not gonna work
like we live in America I'm trying
proactive as well I tried Proactiv first
for however long I feel like it's too
hard to miss cinnamon yeah and then the
cinnamon honey what I was like you're
don't don't give me
I would've ate that [ __ ] so fast you
have no idea my god I just sat there
it's like what's your [ __ ] [ __ ] goes
like I hate it it was a snack I couldn't
help it
I'll be honest the ones that were on my
upper lip at by the end of the 30
minutes it was already guys I didn't
know you had acne to do your [ __ ]
life going up with [ __ ] no no it was it
wasn't the best it wasn't the best so
when did you like start did you always
like dress fashionably too or damn I
gotta see pictures of yourself this is
one of those stories that you hear where
it was loaded the dude that was bullied
made fun of was a dweeb and it suddenly
became a [ __ ] model with his younger
brother on express did that makes no
[ __ ] sense man cuz I'm still waiting
for my moment it hasn't happened yet
okay you know what imma be that story
you have a clothing line what do you
mean yeah but I am hiring people like
you to wear it haha if I wear my own
clothes I look like [ __ ] so I'm trying
to get other people who wear that's so
[ __ ] crazy dude like I would have
never thought yeah well Peter the reason
why we got into fashion is cuz Peter
actually both of us had no sense of
fashion Peter never wore pants only
cargo shorts only cargo shorts all
throughout high school you can ask
anyone women's high school with he only
wear cargo shorts and a beanie so like a
really shitty beanie so he could just
like what put his [ __ ] yugioh cards
in there [ __ ]
possibly possibly yes we loved you Gil
okay you guys you know what I'm not but
you I put a target on our backs but a
lot of people like yugioh though I
remember even like some of my friends
like they [ __ ] with you good they didn't
like say it out loud no yeah but nobody
said it out loud but they did play you
yo cuz I played you yo when I was like
13 I think around there yeah I did for a
year because I like the first one out of
the group that played you yo but then I
got out of it after a year cuz I would I
became a 14 year old doing this [ __ ]
anymore but all my friends did so I just
gave my card to them on you guys play it
and then you gave him your card I have I
still had well this I forgot how [ __ ]
has my [ __ ]
oh I let this guy borrow because he
battled his decks and [ __ ] so I was like
I didn't sell it but I still had like
some dope [ __ ] I can't remember what
they already born because I only did for
a year but I gave it to him I know here
you could borrow it and just give it
back he never gave back
to me and then I was like where's my
[ __ ] he goes oh I don't have it I was
like well I have all your Trigun he let
me borrow all of his try couldn't like
cassette tapes and I was like well until
you give me those cards back your whole
[ __ ] tried and collected mine yeah so
here's a but I need that stuff back I
was like blowing you my cards back so I
still have the tracking stuff in my
closet at home in Sacramento in case he
brings it back yeah but he's still not
gonna get it because anyway you've
basically stole my [ __ ] suit of
limitations yeah I was like just stole
my [ __ ] and I was like whoa
either you get your [ __ ] ass beat I'm
gonna beat your [ __ ] ass or I'm gonna
keep this [ __ ] so I still have it so I
still have this whole like Trigon like
tape collection yeah that's so crazy is
what it is dude so he was battling him
and he lost them it's been stole me
didn't you bet that's what it is I lost
my stuff oh you lost all of them oh yeah
so Peter and I quit so him into it did
you watch the show uh yeah the first
couple you know how they had that Island
yeah so we made an island of our own we
were we went to a school that had like a
park next to it and then there was an
island on it
so one day after school like on a Friday
I was like you know we're gonna make a
tournament you guys pay us $10 we made
wristbands out of double-sided tape and
then you we made stars so you know how
you start with two stars you know most
people sell drugs and they they do cool
[ __ ] like that
this [ __ ] decide to do a you yo
tournament I let me tell you something I
got bullied but then as somebody who got
bullied I would have bullied you why are
you doing this is I need to do it to you
so they don't get to you first
right I I mean I know I've put a target
on my back but it was just what I
enjoyed now there's what you know what
that's the best way to do it there's
nothing to do I was like I so we made
the story man and we had the two stars
for everybody they pay me $10 and Peter
joined the game so I was the game holder
and I was like cool all this pot I'm
taking 50% winner gets 50 mm-hmm
right we had like four hundred dollars
five hundred others coming so I got him
a lot of kids played that [ __ ] dude we
had to it I mean again Asian school oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's right so we
still had it was like still kind of cool
but you know like not to the point where
you make a freaking tournament right
yeah but it's okay a lot of people ended
up coming and and I was also selling
Costco candy at the same time okay
one incoming I was like if you want
candy while you're walking around so it
was like cuz that lasted about 3-4 hours
so there it was like they had to get the
stars from each other and whatever they
were battling each other and Peter ended
up winning oh well he beat this other
guy but the guy got like really upset
that he didn't win he was like you guys
are cheating this cuz you're brothers I
was like listen here we'll split the
winning pot between you and Peters so
yeah he got 125 Peter got Hunt 25 so we
made out with like 300 something yeah
like in like junior high that's [ __ ]
crazy dude how often people got pissed
off no we did the one time stuff and
they found our cards and Saltonstall
stole them all so we no longer had any
cards they stole your car yes because we
could we couldn't play my parents were
like this is the devil's work so you
can't play this so what we did was we
saved up money to get the first deck
like the start of it and when we got
back Peter was so good at strategy
strategizing and all that stuff and I
was good at like meeting the right
people so I would be like yo who wants
to play my brother for keeps so we would
play decks for keeps because some people
had a lot of different decks they're
like sure I'll play you there's no way
your starter deck because we're like
we're only using the starter deck that
we got you know everybody knows what's
in it so they know how to counter it
yeah so though I can just know you're
gonna beat us a Peter found a way to
counter him yeah with the deck that he
was given and he bought like a booster
and put some stuff in there and he beat
him and he got more and more more cards
who stole your [ __ ] we don't know to
this day we have no idea did you go we
got home and we lost the whole tune we
had a big ol 10 like that and there was
nothing in there you guys are so nice
dude like if somebody stole my [ __ ]
[ __ ] I would find that [ __ ] dude
I don't even [ __ ] what were we gonna do
we would have gotten our asses kicked
oh that's these are different times this
ha ha ha Peter Peter could fight mmm he
was smaller and skinnier but he was
always scrappier and he could fight I I
would I would have gotten my ass beat I
would have been like what's the point
I'm gonna I'm gonna go find this guy and
then he's gonna beat me up yeah it's
like even for me like well I guess I
wouldn't have gotten my cards really
stolen because I don't know if people
would just don't give a [ __ ] about cards
back in the day they would just stole
cars just to be an [ __ ] about right
and they would have trashed it in front
of your face but oh well yeah because
like there's no value to that right
because like in my high school there was
value to shoes there was cards also the
[ __ ] you know shoes drugs and [ __ ] like
that so it wasn't like cards weren't
really
maybe [ __ ] her like you know they said
there's like my mice group of friends
that I really liked so like I was a
typical [ __ ] cat allergies my right
eyes I'm about to get rid but oh I was
like I feel it too yeah so I started
rubbing when I forgot about it but you
were touching the cat yep
I forgot but either way I so I used to
like float around different groups right
so yeah it was like the group that I
stated in high school they were really
cool people they're very nicely played
yugioh cards and you know they watch the
anime and all the other [ __ ] which is
really who I am now that's the guy who I
am you know but you know when you grow
up in a bad neighborhood you kind of
feel like you should fit into this group
of people that you grew up with so these
people are the ones that I liked a lot
you know but they that was a very I
didn't realize how small that subgroup
was I kids it was like the honors on a
roll class the only reason why I got to
know these guys is because my parents
forced me to join your honor roll but I
sucked I got seized I got DS you know I
mean I wasn't good at this [ __ ]
hated that stuff but I got but
fortunately for my parents they forced
me to do it that I actually met these
good people they're still my friends
till this day so like for them it was so
weird because I I related them the most
when I started joining honorable classes
I was like oh these people are my my
float like hey they're really nice you
know they [ __ ] play your cards they
watch anime and [ __ ] I like I like these
guys many better than some of my other
friends from from where I grew up you
know so like after a while I just
started kicking it with them and I was
like oh this is this is definitely a lot
more my speed
and so when I remember when they were
playing yugioh cards I was like but I
would like float around a lot of
different groups and it was so weird
because like I you know you just don't
know who you are is yeah which is kind
of cool for you because you just said
[ __ ] jump me did you guys have like a
lot of gangs in your school was just a
very nice school um you know to me I had
no idea that there were all that stuff I
was so sheltered yeah that I had no idea
but there we had a lot of like gay pride
gangs
oh yeah like Korean guys yeah yeah so we
had a lot of that and apparently like
somebody died in our high school there I
had no idea no cuz I was so sheltered I
didn't think anything happened I thought
everybody was a virgin bro yeah I
honestly I was so sure
turns like because my side deals yeah
all I did was just play my games do my
things I create I co-created the anime
club in my high school yeah literally
everybody was like you stupid [ __ ]
you're gonna get your ass beat yeah and
it was like and I was okay so there was
one point in school where I passed by
this room and I saw people rummaging in
there like there was like three or four
people and they were like rummaging
through this stuff and I saw I was like
the heck yeah all the backpacks were
there was only three people and some guy
comes up to me younger guy like younger
grade and it comes up so I came in we're
cool right
I was like yeah bro yeah so he's like
not gonna tell anybody that were in here
taking in this stuff right I was like I
was looking like well I didn't know
until you told me yeah like I was like
no no no of course man and then and then
they got one of the girls who was like
one of the hot girls and it's cool to
come up it was like okay yeah I like
touch my hand I was like okay cool cool
and I like walked past
ran straight to the teachers and a
tattled on hahaha and then they they
caught him but a lot of the stuff was
already gone but they caught him and all
there was like four people three or four
people and they all got like expelled
obviously oh good yeah and everybody in
that classroom was really like thank you
thank you thank you and the teacher
would I thank you shut the [ __ ] up dare
[ __ ] pin this on me that was a big
and then it was like when they saw that
the guys that were like being escorted
out of the school they were like what
come for you yeah oh [ __ ] and nothing
ever happened
thank God but every time I saw them
anywhere near the like the town I was
like I would - man [ __ ] that [ __ ] dude I
was in cross country so I was fast
I was good at I was like you wait you
may be faster on you're very honorable
man dude like I wouldn't even have
computers I just been like they're like
you're not gonna tell anybody I was like
guess not I don't know what's going on
how does what about my way good you know
you know just like growing up like yeah
if you mind your own business like
nothing what happened you guys don't
like that's good good on you though it's
cuz I watch all those animes right
you're like you gotta be the hero yeah
yeah there's like shut up kid dude I'll
just be like shiny [ __ ] dude
you see [ __ ] right I guess not and then
I would have realized after what they
were doing like a month later I'll say
stupid they said that they were stealing
stuff but they're dumb I would have been
like I would just watch that's like rule
number one like you don't [ __ ] do
that [ __ ] yeah just you steal stuff like
you know you're supposed to steal it
yeah like that's just keep going about
your business you don't have to tell me
nothing when I was in uh I don't know
when I was in junior high there's this
guy his name is Chaka Chaka Hassan I
remember this guy there for like for
like 7 times I think he was like 38 by
the time years in junior high
this guy so [ __ ] old but like I just
grew up kind of getting bullied a lot
but yeah the difference is is that I was
just was like that dweeby kid that just
didn't allow people to blow me believe
me because I was a big kid too I was big
you always thought I was this size when
I was 14 I was big already I was like 6
1 6 2 ish around there and so but you
know I was a very nice dweeby kid right
but because I kind of grew up in a
predominantly like I guess it was a very
hood areas like this area in South
Sacramento like if you go off of like
Mack Road like if you're for Sacramento
you don't know like you know if you go
on like what's called Mack Road [ __ ]
I used to kick it there a lot because
like Maya my parents used to work for
this other beauty supply store off of
Mack Road I used to kick it there a lot
and then also like I used to grow up in
this duplex area called Tim woods and
there was like a bunch of like Samoan
bloods over there too and then
it's awful like Florin Road Mack all
those little [ __ ] but you either way
LC but you know those like the kind of
ghetto areas so for me going into a
school that was a little nicer whatever
they were gonna throw at me I have
already experienced a lot worse yeah so
I just kind of had to like have like you
know Tufts kid
yeah if somebody would try to Punk me
didn't matter like you'd get punked you
got to go down swinging because at least
what would happen is it's like they the
people will always go for the easier
target so they might bully me once but
they're not gonna bully the same kid
twice over because I'm just too
difficult
yeah right so it's like well this guy
you know he's he's not gonna go down
that easy so we'll just go bully
somebody next and that's what I would do
yeah so I remember in seventh grade
there was a kid named Jacques he was in
eighth grade he flunked twice at this
point I think those be a sophomore in
high school he should have been kind of
continuations call at this point but
this dude his it was in mr. Flint
his math class and we were learning a
geometry or some [ __ ] like that old
algebra but either way we're doing our
homework and mind you I'm not even smart
hey that's smart at all this guy he
comes up to me and he grabs my paper he
goes I'm a copy of [ __ ]
the [ __ ] I literally snatched it back
out of his hand and mind you when you
look at a kid with like glasses and he's
mean he's fat you think that you could
Punk him but my dad just and I'm an
immigrant too so my dad would just say
like don't let people just push you
around like you can't keep letting
people do that to you
so I just grabbed my [ __ ] and I grabbed
nose like the [ __ ] and it's kind like
literally two years old at me and you
know I'm still a big kid though yeah I
grabbed that [ __ ] out and I put it down
and he goes like what the [ __ ] here I'm
a [ __ ] you up guys remember I stood up I
think he realized how big I was yeah
even in eighth grade I was like maybe
like 510 so I was already big and he was
like shorter for his size and so like I
remember I stood up and I was like what
the [ __ ] I was like oh [ __ ] this is a
big ass little this [ __ ] big you know
I just remembered like being in those
type of situations where somebody would
definitely try to Punk me and I just
wouldn't let it happen yeah even if I
got beat up it's like whatever if I get
beat up at least go down swinging yeah
just because I'm a teachers I'm gonna be
the worst target for you like you could
try to Punk me and take my [ __ ] but I'm
gonna [ __ ] scratch like I'm gonna
scratch your [ __ ] eyes out yeah and
so that would happen so like that guy
just I remember like he stood up my
stood up and what the [ __ ] and I grab my
[ __ ] out because I'm gonna [ __ ] you up
like [ __ ] me up then I don't care you're
not [ __ ] taking my [ __ ]
yeah and mind you if he would have just
said hey yo can I copy off your [ __ ] I
don't know I probably would have given
it yeah especially because I was failing
that class anyway so he it was so stupid
because if he copy my homework he would
fail - yes I suck it was so dumb
he just thought I was the Asian kid so I
was smart and I was like no bro I'm dumb
like I remember dude in junior high like
somebody copied on my homework and they
got mad cuz they got a C and they're
like dude I got a [ __ ] C I was like
yeah I got a C - you copied off my work
not smart you dumbass dub why would you
do that so like people get mad cuz they
would pick on the wrong person it's like
no you don't you don't pick on me dude
like I'm the last person that you want
to copy your homework off though cuz I'm
stupid
at number two I'm just a temperamental
human being so then the wrong but
bullying was so I think it was I feel
like it still goes on today
for sure but but they do it in different
ways right they you know cyberbully
yes some are yeah I think that's way
worse than what we got here at least
when we got pummeled like we could just
deal with it and then we deal with it
right there and then but then you go
home you get bullied now you're online
you get bullied what are you supposed to
do you can't not be on Instagram because
everybody's on it so like I don't know
what to tell these kids it's like oh
what am I supposed to do I just tell you
you just got to be a strong human being
yeah you just got a thick skin or Jam
yeah it's tough it's so much tougher
because it's such a different world like
when we got bullied you're right it's
right then and there you deal with it
right then and there even when I got
bullied like I I would get like when I
first moved here I when I got bullied I
was like yeah okay
whatever I just kind of you know but
then I met a friend my best friend his
name is Benny Lee and he was like what a
guy Korean and he I remember one day I
was getting bullied sixth grade by this
guy who was like in fifth grade he's
pushing me around and all of a sudden I
just see this guy in my view go sideways
mm-hmm and reveal Benny and Benny just
like just [ __ ] chopped his leg out
from underneath him because he saw him
bullying me and he [ __ ] went sideways
and fell flat on his side and he was a
bit he was like don't mess with my
friend that's my friend and he was like
no we were just talking about yours
okay he's like shut up [ __ ] the
temperamental guy and he liked good
people so he could temper I he would
have to be Korean did you just have to
be that stereotype son of a [ __ ] really
was but it's funny because sometimes he
would bully me and I was like he was my
best friend but he would blame me and he
was like well that's Korean culture
though like well at least I'm bullying
you not the other guys I was like fair
yeah cuz Korean bully is different cream
bullying is like it's a hazing yeah so
like older Korean people are especially
if they consider you like your younger
brother they just hazed you all the time
and it's just like that's their way of
showing affection cuz they won't ever
like beat you up beat you up yeah me but
they'll do it in a way where it's like
annoying but they do it because they
love you you know I mean and so it's so
funny because that would happen at
church Crane churches all the [ __ ]
time like all the older people would
Punk the younger people but you somebody
else would try to Punk them
it's not happening like it's hype hold
on a second that's mine that's my puppy
dude like I could spank my puppy with
the newspaper on his nose but you don't
get to do that [ __ ]
so it was that's very less so [ __ ]
Korean it's unreal yeah like having a
church all the time like I know I would
you know when I got old I would do it to
the younger kids too and so but that's
how we would connect and bond and when
we get older that stuff stops because we
just become like so tight yeah you know
so it's like you get that for the first
few years and then after work after was
it goes away
yeah there's become types like
Brotherhood is it's really like blood
brotherly love yeah that's so [ __ ]
funny dude yeah and he's actually the
guy who got me into martial arts like
I've always loved martial arts and
watched it but my parents wouldn't let
me do martial arts but he was like you
know I'm doing taiko no I'll just teach
you whatever I learned from class so
he's the one who taught me my first kick
that I learned was a back kick because
he was like if you ever get cornered you
just turn around you back kick the crap
I know it is such a useful kick as a kid
like people don't expect it yep so I
learned that because of him and I to
this point the stuff that I know he
started it that's crazy dude you're so
[ __ ] flexible too yeah I can't do
that look I can't do any of my kicks
anymore it sucks but you don't need a
kick the head I do want you just gotta
kick the nuts broke your kicks to the
stomach
my god but imagine that's on a face I
probably would be gone but that is such
like your kicks I'm like I need to get
that I was like I lost my hair no one's
calling stop it's hard because like like
kicking is something that I really do
like like back straight kicks are still
something I still use a spine today
till this day cuz if you could set it up
nice you can get it in quick but if you
do miss it you just have to rebound
really well but you won't like if it's
like serious like hardcore spark I
probably won't use it as much just
because you know there's a lot more
forgiveness than light sparring because
I'm retracting it back and you come up
and you tag me in the face if I miss it
then I'm gonna live and arts party with
that [ __ ] it's gonna hurt her yeah
especially if you do it like it hurts
bond you kick them in the gut they'll go
down so like nick has a good setup for
his fan that always gets me in the back
kick he goes he cuts you and then comes
out of nowhere I'm like oh yeah well
Nick always beats us up that's that yeah
he goes easy on us he does because so
easy when we roll with them he's like
smiling armbar and you let go and he'll
go to the next thing is like guy you
here yeah yeah you here and it's like
what is going on how come I'm just
getting my ass beat all over the [ __ ]
place I don't know what's going on you
got long limbs and you got like a heavy
body I don't know how I don't want to
use it but now you're starting to yeah
but when we were when we were rolling
like Bart was explaining to me how to
use my way and I couldn't like compute
what he meant and he goes relax your
legs put your weight over here and then
kind of learn how to manipulate your
weight over and oh so this is what you
be and I put it on Jojo like Oh
as Joe can tell me he's like you have to
use your weight you have to use your
weight as I don't know what you're but
you what does that mean because I think
I'm using my weight yes you're not using
it he goes you're actually you're
holding up the majority of your weight
with your legs and your knees cuz like
when we had when I had sidemount like I
couldn't put my weight on him I didn't
know what it meant
you know cuz you're thinking like
squeeze down but it's actually just it's
relax and then put your weight on him
and I was like oh that's the difference
because he goes you're actually doing a
majority of the work for me so I was
like I couldn't I didn't get it and I
was like oh this we didn't roll this
past Friday I just realized we did I
know we did we did we did you're the one
that [ __ ] me up the most cuz your soul
just got you and you always call your
back you're just like waiting for me to
come in okay I'm gonna get you my guard
you stupid son of a [ __ ]
I guess so lazy I just like to stay on
my bag he just tired me the [ __ ] out did
and Joe was surprisingly stronger than I
expected he's [ __ ] wiggly little
Asian man I got so I got wreck that day
dude it was so exhausting I no clue how
tiring that [ __ ] was gonna be it was fun
though Friday again I did it was fun but
I got I definitely got my ass beat we
need to do more of it I feel like yeah I
mean I'm I'm I know I don't mind it
because either way we're just doing this
for fun yeah you know like striking is
great too but you know if sometimes you
can get like fatigued a lot of things
happen on the ground - yeah Oh a
majority if I end up on the ground
yeah like what's that's what people
don't realize because you get really
close and people just grab and slam so
that's why I actually instead of not
instead of dude you see I'm you geezers
gonna be a part of it like the
submission part I just
grab takedown I want to take down and
hold somebody down like because I don't
want to hit somebody I just want to take
them down hold him down and lock him up
so they can't do when he sit on them
yeah just just calm down relax yeah like
I've seen this this is cliff on YouTube
where there's this guy there playing
basketball here mind you like they're
they're both [ __ ] and nothing should
get to that point but they're literally
in each other's face and I guess like
the guy that was in that video from what
I read he was like a purple belt and you
don't know this stuff but the dude just
comes up to the guy and the guy's like
an inch away from his face and the guy
swings he [ __ ] ducks and it's just
jiu-jitsu baby all the way through
rolling guy he gets him into an armbar
the guy's trying to slide him he lets it
go because his friends get in the way
they pull him off and the guy trying to
swing on him basically gets him in uh I
think he gets him in a knee bar and he
just looks at him straight he could feel
the pressure on his knee and all he does
he goes he goes if you move he'll never
play basketball ever again
the guy just calms down cuz he could
feel the [ __ ] pressure he just stops
he goes you'll never play ball again
that's the most frightening thing I've
ever heard of my life so the other guy
was the one starting everything you
don't get to see who started it but they
were both talking mad [ __ ] and it was
gonna escalate to a fight but but it's
good that he was able to separate
himself from that and stop it before he
broke in yeah because if you cuz the guy
was swinging at him so like that's for
him to say like I know that I could
literally end your whole like basketball
career right here yeah and he looked at
me goes oh you'll never play ball again
calm down dude it scared me I mean it
takes a while to get that gonna do Jitsu
yeah once you're there and you're that
control that's pretty amazing me bars
freak me out
like he locked him up he started like
punching him in the head moved around
rolled around caught him up Bop he was
gonna never play ball again
I can't remember he was a kneebar over
he was like an ankle or something
something with the legs but it was
something with the legs and he was gonna
[ __ ] him up and it was so bad dude
there's it's just crazy dude like it's
just so [ __ ] you useful like I want I
want I want Mariel to learn it
absolutely
that's are they gonna learn it too it's
just it's just good to be to just be
bodily aware of what's going on you know
I mean because I think a lot of people
just don't know distance very well
because even when I spar I'm like I
guess
no my disses as well because I've really
long limbs but I think a lot shorter
than me and it's not just you're tall
you're tall and you've got long limbs
yeah there's like for your height you're
still got long there yeah and so like I
don't realize my reach and I'm like oh
[ __ ]
it's like so when I throw in for my jab
I'm like oh [ __ ] I got to manage this
distance a little better so it's people
just aren't really bodily aware and I
think that's what martial arts really
does for you and also teaches you
discipline because it doesn't come easy
it's repetition repetition repetition
repetition repetition and then you
unlock half a percent after a year one
you get half a percent yeah it was a
lifelong thing because then you start
realizing physical limitations yeah
you're not as flexible as you thought
you were or like when we roll I don't
have the conditioning like I want to do
more but I'm heaving you know cuz your
condition is great it's not my
conditioning though it's because I'm
learning how to be more relaxed during
the role because when I first started
like I was doing the same thing I was
like why am i gassed after one role but
then I realize I'm like most of these
guys that aren't gassed aren't doing
that they're not straining mm-hmm
whereas there's like for stuff that when
you guys are trying to get to something
you're squeezing and I'm realizing I was
like if I'm squeezing too hard and so
hard I'm not in the right position maybe
they just move yeah and that's what what
Nick said to me on Friday he was like yo
you're flowing more yeah it's because
when I when it clicked in my mind I was
like I need to just flow if it's not
working here it doesn't matter how much
yanking I do it's not gonna happen go
somewhere else
yeah yes you've got the back but that
that that choke is not gonna happen I
don't because of because we haven't done
I don't know any submissions really so I
remember because you brought in that kid
Brandon mm-hmm and I had full mouth on
him I was like now what this is all I
know like I don't know what to do I
guess I could use that's great full
Mountain is kid I'm like look what I
started doing is what cuz before I
I still kind of don't know any
submissions from anywhere so for me is
I'm just fighting for position if I'm in
full mount
I just state try to stay there cuz
they're gonna move they're gonna try to
get out of there so I'm gonna stay there
granted you know you can go up closer
closer to get that arm bar but I'll just
stay in full mount until they get me off
and then if they get me in the in a half
guard I just try to get out of the half
guard to get back in the format whatever
so that I can know what position to be
in next and all that yeah cuz like it's
different because when I spar and we're
doing kickboxing like I'm I could flow
better you just because I know a lot of
things are more natural that way yeah
did you just say why Michael Blake like
you know what have I to what do I do
next what is this guy doing this guy's
hurting me why is there pressure on my
newest book is squeezing me like even
Bart if he just squeezes his legs tied
around me I'm like okay see like Bart
can totally just squeeze you out but
like for me there's no way I'm gonna
squeeze you out yeah like my legs are
there's not enough power there yeah
because you can get like if somebody's
got you in a in a half guard yeah and he
just squeezes it could happen yeah it
could I'm sorry not in a guard in guard
yeah yeah he could just squeeze you up
but it depends on like Bart is just like
this rough human being even when we were
doing what we believed had to two wrist
roll and put it under the neck even when
he was wrist roll it hurt it's like it
felt like a punch like cut so deads he
is a wrist wall but his felt like he was
punching the back of my head to the
front of my face like this alone I'm
done dude he's just so massive there's a
lot of people that like like there's
stuff because you know if you can't get
in here because you're you're sorry if
you're like trying to choking in that
are putting their chin down a lot of
people will just roll it to their nose
oh and just that's it will open you up
yeah no matter what it'll be did
somebody got the jaw ripped out or
something like that oh my god yeah I
heard it was a guy that was training in
a different gym he was getting choked
out by his sensei and his he was you
know guarding the the choke really well
so the sensei just grabbed his jaw and
just yanked it to the left anyway
his [ __ ] job was over off the other
side yep they had to wire me shut that's
[ __ ] crazy and I stupid that that a
teacher did that oh that's [ __ ]
insane yeah and then they kicked him out
it's a teacher no they the teacher
kicked out the student that got why his
jaw messed up how did that work
basically he was like you should have
just tapped or maybe you shouldn't try
to kill your students you [ __ ]
[ __ ] what the hell like if he if he
knows like that's the capability of what
he can do he should just stop move and
then instruct the mappers like hey I
could have done this so make sure that
you know how to think like what the [ __ ]
is wrong with that guy basically the
whole leave the ego at the door is an
honest real thing that some people don't
remember to do sometimes that's so
[ __ ] crazy dude I'm not trying to get
hurt like that like this is this is
literally a hobby it's it's for fun yeah
you know so I know a lot and it may save
our life someday ya know but how often
do we get ever yeah and most most of the
times to actually 99.9% in times when
there's confrontation like I'm gonna
walk away for me this is more for a
choreo knowledge yeah so that I can make
choreo more believable believable and
more fun and more interesting that's why
I love like Donnie Yen like Donnie and
[ __ ] to me it's like it looks I mean
obviously it's very stunt based but like
when he does like all the jujitsu and
stuff with it - I thought Tim this is so
[ __ ] dope he's so aesthetic - like
his movements he he knows how to get to
where he needs and make it look dynamic
cuz you can do a lot of Jitsu stuff
chill but you can also make it look
dynamic did you want to go into acting
originally when I first got into the
industry yes because I started off with
doing extra work and then I did YouTube
stuff and JK was actually the first one
who gave me my first like acting stunt
thing for like video not just like
minion guy getting killed but when I was
trying to go into acting
I couldn't book a commercial for the
life of me yeah I couldn't book any
acting stuff for the life of me I just
didn't have the right look because this
was also like six years ago right and I
couldn't book anything and I realized I
was like oh but if I'm a stunt guy and
I'm a ninja I'm hidden you can't tell
you can use my skills I can work and I
started making money that way I was like
sweet this is what I'll do cuz I did
when I did not spare a farm there was an
things done thing basically so I had to
be able to act and I had to be able to
do stunts and then Waterworld the same
thing you had to be able to act engage
with the audience improv and also do
stunts so that was always my thing I
could do both I was like sweet but when
I got to the real world I was like you
don't look like any of these characters
but you can do stunts
so that was stunts became my thing and
and I Peter when I got Peter into it he
booked his first commercial because I
sent him to an audition that I was going
to and I'm gonna make it so he booked
his first commercial apple commercial
national in China
oh wow so then he was like whoa this is
dope so he started doing it and he was a
good actor so he just kept booking and
booking and booking and he had a great
look you know and he kept booking all
these things and I was like dude you act
I'll do stunts yeah and then he booked a
movie and I ended up doubling him for it
oh [ __ ] yeah and then so this was like
our thing I was like you act all do
stunts and then powering just came along
because I was doing stunts with Power
Rangers I you know found out all this
info like do it I want to be a parent
here to act as a Power Ranger like a bee
don't know so when I auditioned and
didn't get it and my brother or Peter
got all the way to producers I was like
okay this is God telling me that stunts
is where I belong
anything is where he belongs so that's
what we decided and then something
happened and he ended up not booking it
something some scandal happened and he
ended up not booking it because somebody
else got recast and then he had to get
real fast it's unfortunate but then the
next season they were like you got to
come back Pete we want you because I'm
pretty sure will book you for this and
he was like yo she should come I was
like dude no I've already said stunts is
my thing
yeah so he made me come and I was like
fine fine and I got again after the
first one I didn't get called back he
kept going all the way and and he
emailed the producers like you haven't
seen what Yoshi can do just give him
another chance yeah give him a different
character and they gave me this
character that I ended up playing and he
was like let me work with the owner and
he coached me for like six hours
whatever we were sitting down he coached
me all this stuff and then and it made
sense for me I was like okay so I had
because I had never really liked because
I took theater in college but this was
like different for TV you know yeah so I
had this coaching with Peter and then
the next day we went in the dish
he was auditioning for the nerdy
character I was auditioning for this
other character big burly character and
it just so happened that they during the
screen test there was like four people
in his category oh there's only two in
my category oh and it just so happened
that the other guy in my category
couldn't really cut it whereas the other
three in his category was like they're
all okay it's fine they can all play
that character that's crazy so I booked
it best [ __ ] car that was my first
like big acting thing and it was because
Peter got me in there that's [ __ ]
crazy yeah so Peter and I have always
seen ourselves are like as brotherly
rivals yeah also like when we're
climbing the ladder somebody's always
gonna be a little blow so we're always
gonna do this and lift and he's gonna
help me lift cuz we can't do it again
yeah a solo you know we're always trying
to do that and I'm trying I'm trying to
get that as as a mindset for myself for
everyone that I know we're always trying
to do this okay you're going more into
film now you know versus he's going to
TV TV he's doing way more TV I'm
definitely more like film is definitely
where I live because I get bored yeah
like I like film about it oh my god what
I did Rangers you know is eight months I
loved it I loved Rangers and I've always
been a fan of the franchise like to a
degree where I would get bullied for it
of course hey you know like I knew
everything coming out with featuring
Yoshi you'll be playing on a Seto Kaiba
I watched the first two seasons you even
knew this last thing you know Seto Kaiba
at ninjas ooh yo I can't remember the
other guys names though yum Yugi Joey
Joey that's right
taya taya there you go I thought it was
so funny it's like everybody has an
interesting name that Joey Joey was dull
I know but it was such a basic ass
[ __ ] name like the guy from friends
but I and they were like kind of similar
they're like yeah they're kind of dumb
and just just kind of burly that's a
sailor that's crazy I didn't know that
[ __ ] and then and then Peter became the
Blue Ranger
after which is so [ __ ] wild did and
they didn't tell me about that because
like we auditioned I helped audition
from the next season and I like dude
Peters got this in the bag like no
wonder actors right for this other
character and then they told me that he
didn't get it they tricked your ass they
tricked it and and it cuz I gave them
this whole idea was like aw dude we
should like pass the torch we should go
to the convention because every two
years they do convention and they
released the new cast they show new cast
and I was like dude we should reveal
them we should be the ones to hand off
the torch that would be so cool
everybody would love it and the guy the
producer was like that's a great idea we
should do that yeah and that was when I
thought that Peter was gonna get it when
it wasn't Peter man I was so bitter the
whole day yeah like I had a panel that
panel we were gonna reveal the new cast
I was so bitter that I was like sitting
down from most of the panel and whenever
they asked me something I didn't I'd say
something but then I was like because
I'm thinking I gotta introduce this
stupid son of a [ __ ] that took my
brother's role exactly and then as they
told me like he didn't get it because of
a race issue and they had to like figure
out who is what and then some of the
people in my cast went over to the other
room like they're not supposed to see
the new cast beforehand and they opened
the doors when they opened the doors
they like went to talk to all the new
people and then they came back I was
like I didn't go because I didn't want
to see them right and I was like who was
it who was the Asian guy they're like
there was no Asian guy I was like what
yeah I was like was there an Asian girl
they were like no I didn't see an Asian
girl either I was like hold up they
didn't cast an Asian person no like we
only saw like three of them or was it
four of them we're not quite sure yeah
and I was like you didn't see an Asian
guy or a girl like originally I thought
they ended up having to go with an Asian
girl because whatever and then they
couldn't have Peter yeah right so there
was like no Asian girl and I was like so
is it an Asian guy I got pissed you know
like no it's not an Asian guy we don't
know we didn't see and I I got even more
mad and until we go to the panel I'm
doing all this with this in my head
right angry
stupid bitter right and then they give
out these papers to everyone to like
introduce the new cast and now all I'm
doing is watching I was like Hispanic
guy white girl
okay black girl it was like where's the
Asian yeah and then the blue hasn't been
released and he the only spot for an
Asian person and I was like if there's
an asian guy that walks out of that room
and it's not my brother like in my head
I'm just like one it's gonna be another
Asian guy and I've seen all the Asian
guys auditioning for and I was like they
none of them were right Peter was better
yeah maybe I've got you know rosy
glasses for Peter oh yeah but I was like
I was mad already then I had me a piece
of paper and I'm like well [ __ ] I am so
mad and so angry that all I can see is
his name on this paper yeah and I was
just like I just kept looking at as it
change don't look more of a fool
you already are yeah [ __ ] change what
is the real name yeah in there like
Yoshi you gotta call it I was like I
can't it's his name I'm gonna say isn't
even that's not him yeah I know that
because they all told me yeah and then
like a Brendan the guy who was my red
ranger right on the left side he like
what's going on he's got this big-ass
gorilla hand yeah he like laughs and
smacks me in the back huh yeah what the
[ __ ] and I look down he's like dude call
your brother up and I was like this is
real yeah do it it's all what I tried to
say it a little bit I couldn't say his
name right he came out I was like yeah
and then I realized like you [ __ ]
yeah yeah but it was it was a great
moment I mean and then he's definitely
more he loves TV yeah and he's he loves
it you know I mean I'm sure he'll do
film as well but for me I just been like
I I get bored even with Rangers I was
like okay what's the next thing yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's tough like um like
people always ask you what would I
prefer doing TV or TV or film and it's
always gonna be film because it's such a
finite project like it's you you get to
be this character you embody it and then
after it's done it's complete it goes
into what goes into post-production or
whatever and then you good to go yeah
why did you find your next character
yeah you know and so that that that's
the part that I like those sequels come
out oh yeah yeah yeah well you know if
even at least you come back after a
while you've already done other
characters
do not hold on you're not like yeah
exactly like I feel like you know can I
like to say this would ever happen to me
like you know but it's more like let's
say you get I got a 20 V show right no
you do this for the next 67 years but
can I do this for six seven years yeah
like I don't I don't know you know yeah
yeah I could I like it was hard for me
to do YouTube for like seven years you
know so it's like can I do that's what
somebody else is tell me to do for six
to seven [ __ ] years yeah unless you
have EP on there if you're EP as well
yeah there'd be some I would be great
for me to be a part of something for six
to seven years like the office like that
would be great
you know but in terms of like a sitcom I
don't know if I could do multicam sitcom
for six or seven years it'll be kind of
rough not to saying that if I did get
the part I would say no but yeah yeah
and totally yeah it's just more like I
don't know if that's like in my
wheelhouse right now yeah not gunning
for it well for sure not but I know
there but film is great you know like I
love film didn't like just there's
something about it that I really like
and you like to be a lead in your film
which is great yeah which is [ __ ]
dope at least you got paid for yours
alright I don't make Mike I'm eight I
mean nothing
I need zero [ __ ] dollars [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're like oh dude your film with you
but you made a lot of money house thank
you [ __ ] wish you [ __ ] I got it but
that's the thing to write like that's
what people sometimes it's just a people
don't know where it goes and you know
like I just got a Tesla it was a oh my
god you're making Bank I was like I got
the cheapest kind yeah it's because I'm
not trying to pay for gas yeah I'm
literally this is the huge car accident
so yeah like all this [ __ ] happened
because you know and it's just people
and perceptions of you change because of
certain things I love about Elon Musk
man he made an affordable car he
promised it and he [ __ ] made it yeah
he made a car that's worth just an
average car like $35,000 I mean
obviously it's not a Honda Civic that's
like 16 grand or whatever yeah but it's
$35,000 there was a something that
somebody was looking at they were like
you can get the cheapest Tesla right now
without rebates and anything for the
cheapest one with auto pilot still at 41
something yeah and meaning that's still
cheaper than like some like high-end
Nissan's and stuff like that yeah I was
like
or like not high-end just like you know
dude man they put out [ __ ] what's the
call BMW you [ __ ] trash company the
[ __ ] I three it goes like a hundred
and like twenty miles and then what it
goes like a hundred and twenty miles
with like a backup gas engine or
something and it it's like after you
make it decent it's like you can go up
to like fifty thousand to forty thousand
dollars and it's [ __ ] trash dude
that's like these thin tires it's
[ __ ] terrible is that the one that
looks like a robot on the back it looks
like a stormtrooper yeah it looks like I
mean like that car should not be worth
like 40 or 50 [ __ ] grand it's 40 to
50 grand yeah like if you get like not I
think the base model is like
30-something is the same price as a
Tesla but the testicles 300 miles yeah
and the autopilot and the interior is
amazing it looks great it's not it
doesn't have like a [ __ ] like paper
thin tires it's so stupid dude yeah and
it goes past 100 miles
you know because that's done oh yeah it
goes double triple it's 300 you're so
[ __ ] 300 my line goes to 68 but you
can get it up to 300 yeah which is
[ __ ] great you know and a BMW also
has like their eye there there it looks
like their version of like a Lambo looks
like an electric car that [ __ ] goes like
90 miles or some [ __ ] like that
you have to charge like every everyday
day yeah at least and that's if you try
to at least 100 plus miles a day yeah
and they don't have a supercharger
network no they don't have a
supercharged so they just have to
$150,000 so I'm saying like BMW so
[ __ ] dumb like they're trying to be
this like this whole electric race game
no who's dumber is people buying it
Jason Chen so somebody body at least
about that oh my god Jonathan Jason I
love you very much sorry Jason Chen out
there and he's driving that car throw
tomato in his face at least you'd be
nice to get those will squish it was an
apple that's kind of that's I throw
parent an Asian pear at his face three
pounds anyways guys do we did like an
hour and 20 those holy [ __ ] good nice
before we leave what do you want to plug
in yeah okay so Buffalo boys is coming
to DVD and blu-ray and it is now gonna
be all over Walmart so your [ __ ]
it's all although physical copies are
gonna be at Walmart and you can buy it
on iTunes if you don't want a physical
copy and you just want to download it
but yeah what's coming up it's coming
out April 2nd so today only April
seconds today okay yeah cool cuz how
cool hey well go ahead and cop that film
just because Yoshi's in it and you know
he actually gave me a link and I forgot
I had an Android and then I was like the
played on this [ __ ] flight that had
no TV anything and I was like I got that
I Toon Link so I'm just gonna download
at the airport and I was like I have an
Android and I think I can't I can't get
in
yeah I didn't bring a laptop I decided I
couldn't watch it but alright now I'm
gonna buy that [ __ ] and watch that [ __ ]
I put on my wall [ __ ] but
genius brain is on every audio platform
out that we're talking about iTunes if
you're on iTunes give us that five star
we need it we got stitcher we got
Spotify we got cast box we got all that
other good stuff man
and if you're on that YouTube community
leave the comments below what you
thought about the interview what more
people we should bring on we gotta get
Peter on here mmm
I get both you guys on okay same time it
should be dope sit on our laps
that's perfect and yeah we'll see you
guys next time I love you stupid sons of
[ __ ] stay fresh and uh adios peace
out